uh let's just bring you some breaking
news now some really sad news um the
former pop idol star darius dinesh has
been found dead at the age of 41. you'll
remember uh darius dinesh from the first
series of pop idol on itv back in 2002
it was the series that uh made him a
star along with the likes of will young
and gareth gates and we have just been
informed uh by his family that he has
been found dead at his apartment in the
united states this is a statement from
his family that says it is with great
sadness that we announced the passing of
darius campbell dinesh darius was found
unresponsive in his apartment room in
rochester minnesota on august the 11th
and was pronounced dead in the afternoon
by the local medical examiner's office
the statement goes on to say the local
police department have confirmed that
there were no signs of intent or
suspicious circumstances the cause of
his sudden death is unknown at this
stage while medical examinations
continue
we ask that you kindly respect our
wishes for privacy at this time as we
come to terms with the death
and the tragic loss of our son and
brother were darius dinesh a scottish
singer songwriter and actor
who
was first
put into the public spotlight during
that pop stars series i mentioned
the first pop idol series which was won
by will young he went on to forge a
successful career
on stage he appeared in the west end in
chicago as billy flynn in two runs of
the production as well as guys and dolls
gone with the wind and other west end
shows he has recently been based in the
united states but that is the sad
announcement of the death of a darius
dinesh at the age of 41 by his family
today